Hi, I'm Tom from the Burp Scanner development team. Today I'm going to talk a little bit about
frequently occurring insertion points in Burp Scanner. This is going to be more of an explanation
than a demonstration, which is why I wandered away from my desk. So Burp Scanner's frequently
occurring insertion point behavior is an optimization that aims to reduce the number
of insertion points being fully scanned as the scan goes on. The idea behind it is there may be
many insertion points that occur on many requests throughout an application, but either never
trigger back-end behavior or always trigger the same back-end behavior, regardless of what
request they're in. The Referrer header would be a good example of this. It'll be in almost every
base request. However, there's a good chance that the web application either completely ignores it
or just feeds it to the same tracking function each time. For these insertion points, there's no point
fully scanning them once we're happy that they're either inert or we've found everything we're going
to find. We'd just be wasting effort. So how does it work? After Burp Scanner has run the full suite
of scan checks against an insertion point in a base request. It makes a note of whether any issues
were found. This yes or no information is stored against a key made up of the insertion points name
and type, so for example a cookie name session, as well as the containing requests host method and content
type. If we scan the same insertion point using this criteria frequently enough without finding new
issues, we'll fall back to a more lightweight scan instead of using the full suite. This lightweight scan
consists of checking for reflections and checking for differences using a fuzzing payload. If we do find
a data reflection or a difference, we'll switch back to fully scanning that insertion point again.
The thresholds for this behaviour kicking in vary between insertion point types and can change
depending on whether we're seeing unique base values for that insertion point each time. They're also
reduced in the fast audit speed. Finally, this optimisation can be turned off completely on an
insertion point type basis in the audit config.